no one has ever asked me the questions
that you've asked me today
[Music]
releasing new music first time in like
three years this time i'm [ __ ]
myself
i remember that video of you
you found out your net worth oh yeah
that's ten [ __ ] million quid sitting
about somewhere where the [ __ ] is it no
label would ever tell you that is the
strategy to become successful you can
philly just put a picture of you wear
towel wraps on your head and these
stupid glasses and we are top off on a
big massive poster on the tube it's less
about being like a polished [ __ ] pop
star whatever people see through that
[ __ ]
you are living an extraordinarily
unhuman life what is the reality i have
really bad anxiety i've never reached a
tipping point until after getting famous
i [ __ ] hate recording albums despise
doing music videos i only do all that
stuff because playing live is this
[ __ ] unparalleled thing that you
can't compare to anything else so like
when that was making me feel shy if it's
like [ __ ] i don't know if i can do any
of this [ __ ] anymore
my dad gave me i left home from the
airport one night and i was twitching
like [ __ ] to the point where he started
crying in the car i couldn't concentrate
on work i was doing because i was so
convinced that i was gonna die
what is the question that no one asks
you that would reveal the most untapped
answer
i think
before this conversation starts i've got
a favor to ask from you 74 percent of
people that watch this podcast
frequently haven't yet hit the subscribe
button and nine percent of people
haven't yet hit the bell to turn
notifications on the bigger this
platform gets the bigger the guests get
so if you could do me one favor if
you've ever enjoyed this podcast please
hit the subscribe button and turn
notifications on
without further ado
i'm stephen butler and this is the dire
of a ceo i hope nobody's listening but
if you are then please keep this
yourself
[Music]
lewis hello
when you look back and i was reading
about your childhood i found it really
fascinating when you look back at those
um early
early early dots that you i think
sometimes in hindsight we can connect
and go ah
that was the reason i became the person
i am today well that was a really
significant early moment what were those
first early dots that you connect and go
that's why
i ended up where i am
today um i think for me it's probably
the first one i can remember is like
being i remember just being on holiday
in france we used to go on these mad
like
caravan holidays in france me my mom my
dad and my
two older brothers my older sister and
uh there was like i don't know for some
reason i had become obsessed with queen
i must have been like four years old um
but like we got like a cd and the like
one of you remember those free cd
newspapers like oh yeah well you would
pull out stuff so we got that
and it had like we were rocky by queen
on it
and i had
we are the champions as well and i
remember like just i became obsessed
with and i was like listening all the
way through don't they um
we were going so we drove from scotland
to france so it was like i just remember
listening to that constantly on repeat
and then being i don't know if i'd ever
showed an interest in
singing prior to this or being a singer
but
i remember
we were at like one of those like cat
like a band was playing it was like a
karaoke thing like one of the family
entertainment nights or whatever and
then for some reason i just like asked
if i could go up and sing and we were
rocky by queen um
and it was glad and i went up and i did
it and there's a picture of me doing it
like i'm tiny and i've got this maker
foreign
so i did it and then i think
i've got a buzz for whatever and for
whatever reason i asked if i could go
back up and do another song and i did
another song and it was like for me
that's the first kind of memory of like
this like singing and getting a buzz for
like
well i'm up here and i'm doing this
thing in front of people it's like again
i i have no other memory of like
singing prior to that but this was like
just the first time i'd ever like got up
in front of people and sang and been
like oh this is like a
oh he bit of a buzz like even at four i
mean which is
mad to think now but like um yeah i
don't know what
sort of possessed me to get up and do it
but it was so that must have been
[ __ ] i don't know like i would have
been
like 2 000 or something maybe that
happened um
but yeah i still don't i still can't
like
put a finger on why i did it or what
what the reason was for getting up on it
but um you're four years old four years
old yeah yeah it was it was a strange
one and it was like a like a party or
something it was like uh like you call
these [ __ ] it's kind of like these
kind of package holidays that you go on
my family they have like kids clubs and
they have like entertainment nights so
it's like everyone kind of congregates
in this
theater kind of but in the middle and
it's like
then they have a on and they have like
i don't know [ __ ] puppet show or
something like i don't know i can't
really remember i haven't i haven't been
back since
i don't often hang around
they didn't put me back but um
but yeah so then it was like um yeah it
was just that it was that was the first
time we did it and it was
yeah i can't
i can't i can't put my finger on why
what were you like at that age at that
sort of under 10 age in terms of
confidence and because to say you know i
want to go up on stage and sing in a
bunch a group of friends strangers seems
like quite an
abnormal thing for a child to volunteer
to do toy um i think prior to being like
10
and prior to like
i don't know yeah probably go to high
school or whatever on that maybe not
even like that but like
when i was younger i was definitely
quite
like outgoing i'd say like i was quite
i remember i watched them
when i was like five i watched austin
powell's like i was like religiously
watching austin powers i don't know why
my parents allowed me to do that but
like i would like go to family parties
and be asked to recite like i'm a fat
bastard at austin post like the big fat
guy that he pleased please
i'd be asked to like recite
parts of his thing and i would do it in
front of everybody you know the rest of
it was but it was never like again it
was never singing it was just like
acting the goat and like take the piss
and
yeah i would get up and do recite all
these fat bastard bits and [ __ ]
um so yeah i was definitely like more i
was definitely like a
an outgoing kid i think
um i definitely like to be
i was probably allowed and i kind of
like to be like
i guess i i i kind of like people for
feedback yeah yeah i like feedback i
like people watching me do things i like
seeing people enjoying something that i
was doing do you know why um i don't
know
it's
it's a strange one because i i never i
guess i never put much thought into when
i was five or whatever but i don't know
if it's like
i don't know if maybe like making a like
my parents laugh or something made me
feel like oh that's a buzzer whatever or
like
i don't know yeah i've sat here with
quite a lot of comedians you know jimmy
carr
russell kane russell howard and and
that's been one of the really
fascinating things for me is like trying
to find out why at a young age
they got a real buzz from
performing and making people laugh and
actually i think it was jimmy carr that
said something to me he said
instead of you know because there's this
kind of stereotype that you do that
because you're depressed and you're
trying to i don't know but jimmy carr
said to me when when you see that
behavior in a comedian don't ask them if
they're depressed ask them which one of
their parents were they trying to cheer
up all right well interesting yeah
that's as interesting i don't know my
parents
when when i was i went to a therapist a
couple years ago who had said my
my mum's mum died when i was three
of like cancer
not like cancer that was cancer
and then a year after her aunt
like committed suicide um who was
and sorry my mum's sister my aunt
committed suicide so my mom lost her mom
and her sister in like
the set like within a year of each other
so i don't know if maybe that's like
i'm quite like a hypochondriac and i'm
i'm kind of like
i always think i'm out of dying and when
i was younger my mom used to talk man i
used to always be like have you locked
the doors like even when i was like four
or five or whatever and a therapist told
me that was kind of like that might be
because of like being exposed to the
fact that people
are gone like people
disappear people aren't like i was aware
of what death was at a young age so i
don't know if maybe that's like
having seen
like that sort of like that sort of like
profound sadness
and my mum when she's like
lost her mom and lost her sister i don't
remember that's was it profound sadness
that you saw oh for sure like i mean
it's obviously i mean i can't imagine
losing
my mom at this i mean i'm 25 my mum
would have been 34 when she lost her mom
um so
yeah for sure like i still i have like
like vivid memories like
going into my mum's room she was crying
a bit i think this might have been my
man died but her crying in bed
and talking about like
and then being like having to tell me
all like
you know i passed away or whatever or
like i just didn't i wasn't feeling
aware of what was going on but i just
saw her so
like heartbroken and so
yeah so distraught that this happened so
i don't know maybe that's that's an
interesting thought of like i don't know
if maybe that's fed into it and like
me doing anything i could to like either
cheer them up or distract them whatever
i don't know but um
but yeah it's an interest in him
how old were you when that happened
i was three with my granddad and
three and three
quarters
when my aunt er come out suicide
so i was i was young for sure
it's it's really i don't think people
realize how much kids can feel the pain
of their parents right
i had an incident with my um
sister-in-law and her her and my niece
where my
probably the instance that taught me
this lesson when my sister-in-law was
crying um was upset about something and
i just looked down at my knees and my
niece is glued up and my niece explodes
in tears as well yeah that kind of
relationship we have like of intuitively
knowing if our parents are feeling
something
of course i think that yeah i think as
the people kids do i mean it's a thing
now where people are kind of talking
about more kids to see a lot more i
actually watched that in joel wick's
documentary a few weeks ago when he was
talking about his parents addictions and
things and he says like yeah kids see
so much more and are aware of so much
more than we actually know i i totally
agree because even now if i'm at a
funeral it could be for someone i have
never met in my life
but my mum knew them if i turned around
and my mum's crying right yeah like it's
a mess so it's like something that's
like obviously
learnt like you see your mum crying it's
listen
it's one of the worst things you can
possibly see your mom or your dad or any
of your brother's sister's
unpaid or crying or like um really going
through something and i think
yeah it's something that just does even
though it
sticks with you and fears i read the
study about these monkeys these recess
monkeys and it showed that if the mother
recess monkey had a phobia of spiders
then all of the babies would be scared
whenever they saw a spider and that kind
of show you you're talking about
hypochondria there you're talking about
like um using your parents as a steer as
to what is dangerous what is sad you
know all those things do you think that
you're you you said you had like a
hypochondriac yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah do you think that came from
your mother's caution i think it's not
necessarily my mom's
she's not like uh she is like the least
like if i phone and i say mom i've got a
headache i'm dizzy i think i've got like
a tumor or something she'll be like
shut the [ __ ] up you're fine like listen
take some paracetamol go to sleep you'll
be grand i'll see you later my dad
is a very
i the older i get the more i understand
that my dad i get all my anxieties and
things from my dad my dad's like a
worrier for sure and he
he's a catastrophizer as well like his
mind goes to like
yeah the other day he went um to chat he
went to my brother's house chat from the
door my brother never answered my
brother was in the shower
and uh my dad had convinced himself
there was a gas leak in the house and my
brother like an immediate jump like no
no like like stepping ladder to that it
was chat the door no answer chat with
her again right gas leak if something's
wrong banging the door my brother comes
out and i tell and he's like what the
[ __ ] are you doing this is like mental
and my dad's but that's like i mean it
comes from like an amazing place but
it's something that he just
has in his mind and i think he he's a
hypochondriac as well he kind of
has
yeah i i think i've learned that from
him in the sense that he's he's a he's a
warrior in that sense but i do think
that
because i never thought about the
my aunt and
grandmother passing away is like a
a big thing in my childhood i just which
is which now when i say that out loud
it sounds mental because when i'm like
oh it wasn't a big thing however but
like
so i think it's probably that like that
sort of like
awareness of death and awareness that
you're not around forever and your
parents like because then immediately
i'm like oh my mom's passing away like
my mum will probably like i mean that's
immediately in your head as a kid so um
i i can't remember why i got into asking
with her about like locking the door
when i was
a kid and she was have you looked i
don't understand and i still don't
remember how that became a thing
but um but yeah no so i think
i definitely get a lot of my
hypochondria and my worry and my anxiety
from my father
and my my mother's quite quite calm cool
and collected if i'm
the older i get the more i'm realizing
that's what i mean
but yeah
i sat here with um a guy called jack
jack mate he's called and he talked
about health anxiety in ocd and he
really opened up about it and i you know
people use these terms flippantly they
said i've got ocd i've got i'm sorry i'm
hyper conjunct and they use them so
flippantly to describe like the tiniest
little
something's not neat i've got ocd or uh
you know you you might
find a lump and go you know jokingly say
it's this and yeah then someone will
flip and they sell you're a
hypochondriac but the reality
of
being a hyper contract or ocd is as jack
taught me it's very very different
mm-hmm talk about saying what is the
reality so i think so that i i've got i
have really bad anxiety
like anyway but which i never really
had never reached a tipping point until
after
like
getting famous i never had a panic
attack until after i was famous or after
i was a musician or after this was like
after they got to like a height
um but the hypochondria i get i guess
like looking back now i'm like oh i was
like such an anxious kid but then
because now i understand that a lot more
and i've got a therapy and i speak about
it with people and i'm trying to learn a
bit more about it i kind of look back at
things at that time
and realized that that that the behavior
was was the result of
anxiety but that hypochondria thing was
probably where it was started and it was
like
i would be like
i'd be walking around school like moping
and [ __ ] like
black sort of like blink of a blanket
for you and everything and i was just
like couldn't concentrate on work i was
doing because i was so convinced that i
was gonna die and that i had this
[ __ ] horrible disease and that
um
that yeah that that i was good that i
was going to be over and i was going to
have to go to hospital
i was going to pass out or have a
seizure i've never done none of that has
ever happened to me i've nev i've
touched wood never been in hospital for
anything serious i've never broken a
bone i've never
had any major i've never had a surgery
i've never had any major illnesses or
anything like that um
at school when i was in primary school i
never missed a day off i never had a day
off i was always
never had i was never ill
um
secondary school i was off once like so
it wasn't like it wasn't like um i had
calls for any of this it was just like
in my head just thinking and i think
maybe that's a thing as well of like i
don't know if that maybe never actually
being ill
i didn't know what being really hell
felt like so my mind would maybe maybe
conjure something up in that respect
but um but yeah no at the school it just
became sometimes it could become like
just
really like
again at the time i didn't understand it
i and and the symptoms of anxiety like
being dizzy and [ __ ] i used to kind
of always go like
i just think big deep breaths
um all the time and and i used to make
this noise which i still make when i go
like
um
and it's like
i found so basically and now looking
back i realize that's all anxiety and
actually got diagnosed with tourette's
like
two months ago or something like that
really yeah yeah which was which was to
me made
when they said i was like oh that kind
of makes [ __ ] sense because i always
thought tourette's like [ __ ]
on that i didn't realize it could just
be like
text bodily thingies but um so i kind of
yeah as i say like looking back and i
realized it was all anxiety but
if i thought i had a brain tumor and i
was like
um
and i was like worrying about it so much
and getting access that i was dizzy that
would then feed back into the
oh i've got a branch in because i'm busy
all the time why else would that be does
it i mean i even got so bad a couple of
years ago
um
that i paid i went and paid for an mri
scan cancelled i've met play austin set
a limits festival um in austin and i
just had to cancel the trip because that
my anxiety about i think there's someone
serious around me i got so bad that i
was i can't get on a plane and go to
austin and be away from home i need to
go get an mri scan or i need to [ __ ]
really see what it's going about so i
went and got it and obviously there was
nothing in my head
that was fine and no one can talk you
out of those when you're in that moment
call your mom you call your friends you
tell people no one can talk you out of
it i can do it now because i've like
done therapies and i've kind of been
able to
sort of
understand my own anxiety and stuff a
bit more like
that has made it easier for me to kind
of talk myself out of
these kind of
situation at least kind of holes that i
can dig myself in my head
my mum's also very good at my dad's
absolutely useless because
because he's [ __ ] like he's anxious
himself
he's just like [ __ ] all right he's
he's mental but um
so my mom yeah she's she's really good
at like if i'm having if i'm having a
panic attack
my mom has to like there's nobody else
that can like
taught me a little bit for sure
definitely
like that by the way my mom has had to
sleep
in my bed
as as recently as like a month ago
because of how bad
my anxiety got at one point but i think
that was that was alcohol related that
had been on a bit of a bend a couple
days before but like it gets to a point
where i'm like
i can't
i just can't [ __ ]
i can't envision like i can't
like
i can't
imagine
at not being something like
life-threatening or like
super serious because of how [ __ ]
like sometimes like things don't feel
real
someone who'll say something to me and i
won't understand what they're saying
like it's [ __ ] it gets like proper
proper intent um
but yeah that's kind of the hypochondria
as i've got older is as lesson it's only
when i start to have a panic attack or
like i start to get really anxious
that i'll go right that's i think so i'm
dizzy
that's probably anxiety you're fine i
know there's a voice in the back of my
head that goes but what if it isn't
worth something wrong with me what if
you're about to pass out
and then in some situations i just i get
my head tells me like oh you're about to
have a panic attack you're going to have
like
and then that is enough like that's
enough hypochondria like yeah it's mad
um
so as it's still something like ongoing
like that that i deal with but um
it's definitely getting better i've i've
started taking like
my medication for it i've seen a
therapist more regularly
um
again the tourettes thing was like a
good
sort of
a look like and it was kind of nice to
hear because i started doing this but i
twist my shoulder it's actually okay
today but um
that became
so like bad that i was like this has to
be [ __ ]
something serious like more neuron
disease juggling all that [ __ ] and like
again just the wheels starting turning
and all rested so
that finding out the tourist thing was
fact was like a nice sort of like oh
that's okay that's cool because i don't
mind like i don't i never really think
that like i have like a mental illness
of any sort i just think sometimes i get
really anxious and it's fine you know
what i mean it's like it's just one of
those things but i don't see it as like
this big thing i'm quite like
i'll talk to anybody about it if i'm
having a panic attack room i'll be like
i'm having a panic attack by the way so
just
do with that information what you will
and you said that on stage before yeah
i've done it on stage i had the panic
attacks on stage we
actually we played
and we did an arena tour in march 2020
like right up and like just before
covert kicked off
and i don't know it was like
obviously it was like basically it was
kind of the combination of this album
campaign that we had done for the last
record and
things were great and it was like we
played australia and done some amazing
shows in australia in january
europe in february
and then march was
come back like kind of nice sort of
[ __ ] victory lap
look what we've done this is great
arenas can't believe we're doing this in
first album amazing it was the worst two
weeks of my life that was [ __ ] [ __ ] i
hated every minute of it like if you
look at videos of me on stage i'm doing
this twitch
that was so bad that it was just
like i was i couldn't speak between
songs i couldn't i could i had to stop
songs and start over again
i saw lots of tweets
one
being
like
particular that was like all loose is on
with fully on cocaine like [ __ ]
there's like twitching [ __ ] and all
that [ __ ] and then obviously i'm like oh
no people think i'm cookie and that feel
feeds out of my
thing i do i mean i don't and it was
[ __ ] it was but i was [ __ ]
horrible and i think i played the first
two shows were in glasgow they were like
the first two arena kicks from glasgow i
remember walking out and
this is like a kind of big colosseum
thing in the hydro in glasgow
and it's like i'm walking out into the
middle of the
arena empty arena with mum and dad my
sister and looking around the me like oh
[ __ ] this is like
it was just i think things had got to a
point
where they were bigger than
like i was seeing how big it had gone
like during the first time because
the way it worked was
my songs had gotten
we were kind of always playing catch up
with ourselves in terms of
the size of venues we were doing so like
when we could have done 2 000 cap rooms
we were doing a thousand cat rooms and
then
like so on and so forth so it became
like
it was kind of nice because i was like
oh this is great like
songs flying
like that next song's done really well
as well
like we're playing these knife rooms
that the crowds are meant oh this is
class and i think yeah the the arena was
like the arena shows were like oh [ __ ]
this is
real this is huge there's a difference
between 2 000 because that's another
thing i've got about an issue with
especially in the uk it's really hard to
go from 2 000 capacity rooms to 16 000
capacity rooms it's like there's very
rarely in between when i probably can do
like 10 you can do it like five and
places but it was just like [ __ ] this
is like a big jump
and in that thing of like disappointing
people really came in here and then just
like
i don't mind support become being a
support act i always love because if i'm
shy no one gives a [ __ ] because it's
like
who cares who's that who is this guy
later i mean we did supported sam smith
on tour
and like they were really gracious and
have this on and uh but everyone's there
to see sam no one's there to see
me like i mean so if i go out and have a
shake gig it's like
grant i'm [ __ ] off this is great i
mean so uh
but when it's like people have bought a
ticket to see you it's not a festival
where there's loads of other people on
yeah literally you it just became quite
it was quite intense how old were you
then when you walked out with your
family into that gig and you looked up
at the stadium 23 23 23 years old um
it was my yeah it was intense i think
it's because as well like
i just maybe i think in my head i was
like oh you you can't as i've got i've
got really bad like and everybody i
speak to who's done well this like
imposter syndrome thing where it's like
i don't deserve to be doing this what
the [ __ ] it like why am i
[ __ ] up here doing this i feel like a
[ __ ] absolute
like
i don't know just like a [ __ ] that i
shouldn't i shouldn't be in this
position and i've always had it and it's
like we do the self-deprecating pattern
like on [ __ ] interviews and stuff
which i do love is like take the past
but like
the the important stuff i had never been
more
insecure and unsure of myself than after
i did really well that's so interesting
yeah because i've heard that before yeah
yeah like like even now like
going back to writing new music after
we've done these [ __ ] shows it's like
i thought i was gonna go in and be like
right i've had a couple of hits
relax guys here we go this is gonna be
lovely easy-peasy i was [ __ ]
second-guessing myself all the time
i was like
i would start writing a song and then
immediately no that's [ __ ] like just
constantly like
self-sort of like
like just [ __ ] just ah that's [ __ ]
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] like
looking at what we did before
obviously covered happened you have all
this time to kind of like
look back on everything you go oh for
[ __ ] sake that was kind of got a away
from us about there
the song one of the songs went number
one in america and i was like there's no
way i can do that again does that just
seems like such a
such a [ __ ]
um
such a [ __ ] claim and something that
i'm just not capable of i don't it feels
like someone else did it
so i mean
and now i'm like oh no i'm comparing
yourself to that person yeah i'm like
lumped it's like we were saying before
like that thing of like even now coming
out to do the interviews and stuff it's
like [ __ ] i don't know if i can do any
of this [ __ ] anymore because it's been
it's been [ __ ] easy it's been like
three years
do you know who's sat here before you
was was bear grylls and bear grylls said
to me he said the more successful i've
i've become the lower my confidence has
become because bear grylls now is he's
when you like if your mate eats
something crazy or doesn't mean crazy
you go who do you think you're a bear
girl he's actually become synonymous
with the word like so his identity is
this like extreme
you know whatever and he's now looking
up at his own identity going
how the hell am i ever going to be bear
grylls
and it was crazy to hear him say like
his confidence is at like pretty much an
all-time low because of his success yeah
because he's competing with his own
accomplishments which is
not an easy place to be yeah and i have
to agree with that i feel like as well
it's such a weird position to be in
because you walk into a room
like and as people
like
this sounds wanky as [ __ ] but like
i have to i have i have to assume in
some regard that people around my age
have at least heard about me in passing
and i always just assume
when i go into room i just assume people
in that room don't like me
like that's just my thank you that's my
like default position of like i don't
know why i don't know why it is but i
just like
it's just something i always have and i
always like
if i go to a pub
and like i'll walk in a pub like i'm
like oh [ __ ] people probably like
walking up to the bar or like if someone
comes up and says hello and i'm speaking
to them and i think it puts you with
them
i think oh everyone else in this book
i'm a wanker i don't know it's like i
don't know if it's like
when did that start um maybe like
end towards the end of 2019 probably
yeah um i don't get wrong i [ __ ]
being famous is fun it's great like you
know what i mean why do you think
they're not gonna like you uh i don't
know it's just like i don't know what i
i just assume that they've probably seen
something online like a video i've done
or an interview i've done or they've
heard the songs and they think oh it's
music's [ __ ] oh they've seen interview
and they think i [ __ ] hate that card
can't stand them um yeah i don't know i
just always assume that people have got
this
um
i don't know this view of me
that they maybe don't like i don't know
again i couldn't really put my finger on
why like i don't i don't i don't hate
myself like i think i'm all right thank
job i mean but i think um
it's just that i don't know i i don't
know if maybe that thing of like
being like in pub in the public eye like
you're so [ __ ] exposed
to like
all this [ __ ] and it's like
yeah it's just a bit it's a bit of a
i don't know it's a bit of a it's a bit
of a you walk into a room and you feel
like
oh [ __ ] this is do you feel like it cuz
because i'm on because i've started
doing dragon's den now so the podcast
was like you know big people know before
but there's this whole new demographic
yeah now this bbc one demographic where
if i'm in the airport i'm if someone
just glances at me i assume oh they're
you're going to come over and say
something away so you kind of live with
this constant paranoia yeah you're kind
of like oh yeah anyway i just keep my
headphones on and i don't i look at the
[ __ ] floor
i'm like do you two hold up
and it's like that like that sort of
like you feel like
squeeze that and i don't know i love
when people come up and
i i love taking pictures people i love
speaking to people and hearing people's
stories about how they love the music or
like even i get a lot of people go um oh
i think your music shape but i hate the
funny you know that stuff and i'll
accept that as well that's fine cool um
but
is it cool yeah i think it's fine you
can't
my music's not going to be for everybody
i'm really aware of that my personality
is definitely not going to be from doing
fully with that i think
the fact that people come up i like the
fact that people
feel that they can say that to me and i
won't take offense you've kind of
invited that there haven't you yeah yeah
because and i'll because that's how i am
like i'm you you would really really
have to say something
horrible about i don't know what you
could say to me that i would take
offense i'm very like
i don't know if it's mark bringing in
scotland or just being scottish or
whatever like that
like
i don't
take offense to things really
like i've seen some [ __ ] pretty
ridiculous things written about me
online and on twitter all the rest of it
that really does not like
you say you're very self-deprecating
yeah of course why
uh i just think it's funny i think i
think but again i think that's a very
scottish thing and that's a very
like
we kind of all
well when i grew up everyone just took
the piss at each other it's quite i
don't know it's quite a bad thing and
not a bad thing it's gone
you never feel you never want to get
ideas above your station like you never
even when i was starting out music i
just always i never thought we'd get to
this point or the things we get that's
big because i just always thought oh
that would just that just doesn't
think it might be a bad thing as well
because it maybe stops a lot of people
from going to achieve things or trying
to reach for stuff like i on i've said
before like if i hadn't met
my manager on my label and stuff i would
still be in pubs just playing tunes at
the weekend and all that it's not like
or i'd be playing weddings and stuff
like because i would just not assume
that this was on the cards um
but i think yes i i think there's
something nice and
don't get me wrong around my friends i'm
slagging them off like nothing else and
they're doing the same to me and it's
like
you kind of figure out like what your
flaws are
by the way your friends the stuff your
friends pick out
and i don't know like on tour we say
some [ __ ] horrific stuff to each
other to pursue each other and
that's all fine because we love each
other it's grand but like i think in
general if if i can
it feels better to make people laugh
like at me than other people like i
would rather make someone laugh at
me than
grab something else and take the piss
out of them before
is there a harm
because i i've heard some of the things
you said you know you said i mean i know
they're jokes but you said things like
people women find me equally repulsive
in australia and whenever there's you
take a shot at yourself and i i do want
it because if my one of my good friends
was always self-deprecating i would tell
them to stop yeah
because i would be worried that that
those words might knock their own
confidence or something it's like you
don't talk like be nice to yourself like
that's the thing i'd like i think
you're talking like
if you had like a child would you want
someone to say the things to your child
that you say about yourself
i get that
completely and i understand that but i
don't like self-deprecate
constantly in my private life sure i
mean i don't like yeah um
it's something that
has become kind of synonymous with me
doing
interviews and all the rest of it and i
do do it
a lot in my private life but not like
it's not like a constant every sentence
on interviews and things like that do
you think it's kind of self-defense in a
way from it could be yeah i think as
well yeah look my first album's called
divinely uninspired to a hellish extent
which is like
kind of getting
seeing my album [ __ ] before i can see my
album [ __ ] um
i think it's like it's nice to take the
power away from people because it's like
well i [ __ ] say that first
i mean like it's like i think it's quite
a as good as good takes the power away
from other people i think in in that
regard so i i do think there's probably
something in that but um the way i get
the way i see it i don't really feel
like it's
dragging me like for example the stuff i
see myself in my head when i'm hungover
that is like damaging stuff like that
sort of thing like when you're hungover
and you're like
kind of just that self-loathing and that
sort of like that's the stuff that if i
said to myself all the time i'd be like
whoa you need to [ __ ] like chill out
i was like jovial and it's never stuff
that like
i can't change
you know i mean it's not like things
like
that i'm like if i'm calling myself
chubby that's not like my i can't i can
do something about that like do i mean
i'm choosing like not you know what i
mean so it's something like
um like
there is an aspect as well like you kind
of
people you get to a point and doing
interviews like especially radio
stations that we do just say the same
thing over and over again so as it's the
same in that regard of like
people say a lot like you're very
self-deprecating it's like well
yes but these are i'm going to ask the
same questions everywhere i go so i'm
just kind of like rewarding a lot of
this
self-deprecating pattern and then the
rest of it so
yeah i mean i don't think
second time around it's going to be
quite like i don't know
how it's going to play that's what i'm
saying about like turning it on again
and all the rest of it like
it's just that's it's gonna be
interesting to see like how things play
out this time around because it's like
yeah i'm not just gonna come out and say
the same stuff how did you how do you
feel about the second time around
give me the full range of emotions so
this is your second kind of yeah
releasing new music first time in like
three years first time was just a smash
mega ultra hit yeah
some mate call it that yeah um and um
[ __ ] crazy yeah it's wild it's wild
so this time i'm [ __ ] myself but
this is the problem i think the nature
of the music industry it's a big problem
with i mean it's got so much better and
i've had a lot of support from
everyone around me no one forces me to
do anything
no one really we were able this is like
almost unheard of but like we were able
to go away and make new music and bring
it to the label and be like this is the
new music that we're going to put out
and they said
great thank you we will now do our job
with this so it's like a lot of people
have like maybe an nr who's quite
oh no he's changed this changes and that
we were given like the first album i
think um free reign to kind of go do
what to do people have always checked up
on us
but i think in the music industry
and then maybe any industry it's like
you get a number one single and
immediately it turns to
uh yeah but can i do it again yeah and
then you do it again and then i mean
like ah but how's the album doing and
it's like how are the tickets there's
always something else the goal posts
always [ __ ] changing so it's this
constant sort of like
state of [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i need to like
right you can't it's like that thing i
mean it's so
i've spoken about to death but like that
thing i've not been able to sit back and
enjoy it because you're always
on the move to the next thing and on the
move the next thing i think that's why
uh during lockdown i really struggled as
well because it was like oh the next
thing that the next thing and then there
is no next thing now because we're all
covered and all that [ __ ] and it's like
what do you do now and then you just
i'll have all this pen up [ __ ] how
was that exactly
it was um it was intense for sure
because you know what when we first got
announced well when kobe first got
announced as if it's a [ __ ] album
about him
coming this summer um but i think um
when cody first got like kind of
when the lockdowns first were announced
we were all [ __ ]
i think that was about like i was might
go on tour to an america to support now
horn
but having had just had the [ __ ]
horrible experience i had over two weeks
i was in a position to realize i don't
know if i can perform live anymore
without having a panic attack it was
that bad that every single night had a
panic attack i was twitching it was
[ __ ] horrible people who i knew
would be watching the gigs and they
would come back after and be like that
wasn't we didn't enjoy watching that gig
like that was really [ __ ]
hard for us to see you in that position
did you ever in those moments
question what you were doing yeah for
sure but i i questioned what i was doing
a lot in lockdown as well like it was
that it kind of started it's like [ __ ]
if this is making me feel this bad
and that it was [ __ ] so heartbreaking
as well because sorry i keep having this
mic but i was so heartbroken about it
because playing live was the is the
the best bit about music like i [ __ ]
hate recording albums it's stressful
it's a pain in the ass
promo i kind of i get into a point where
i quite like it and it's kind of like
fun but it's not like why i'll get into
it i [ __ ] despise doing music videos
i hate doing photo shoots hey get my
photo taken i only do all that stuff the
only reason i started writing songs was
because i thought okay i thought like
people who i was watching like bands
like green day are [ __ ] other monkeys
oh they write their own songs so i if i
want to play live i have to write my own
songs
um
the the so like the only reason i'd do
any of this little [ __ ] i'll put up with
this little [ __ ] is because the
playing live was just [ __ ]
unparalleled thing that's there's
that you can't compare it to anything
else takes you back to being for that
karaoke right totally a hundred percent
and it's that same buzz every single
[ __ ] time like i mean i mean unless
you have a [ __ ] shotgun it's terrible
but um and then you're depressed for
like three weeks but um
yeah that buzz is just
unbelievable so like when when that was
making me feel shy i was about like well
this is [ __ ] horrific
and i was like i don't know how if this
has made me feel this bad
why
continue to do it and then at times
making new music and stuff i was like
when i would get really down to myself
i'd be like [ __ ] is this actually worth
it all the rest of it i never actually
got to a point where i was like
oh
i'm going to quit i'll like think i
don't think it was ever something that
was serious in my mind because i've
literally never done anything else and i
would be [ __ ] useless anything else
i'm a lazy [ __ ]
like serious and i don't know that
sounds like i mean self-deprecating i i
am i'm just aware of that as a genuine
flaw that i am i'm trying to take the
steps to correct
honestly it's so [ __ ] i'm so bad for
just like see like just sitting on tick
tock and [ __ ] scrolling through that
and this and i think as well getting to
the position i got and
my first album i was like [ __ ] now i can
like really [ __ ] be lazy like now i
can turn this [ __ ] [ __ ] right up it
was wild so like
at point's house it's like [ __ ] i just
do this and that but i think for the
most part i was never seriously
considering like stopping like
completely but it was definitely
something that and my mom and dad had
raised that uh raised it to my family
and friends was like if this is making
you feel that bad especially when my
tourette's thing was really bad and i
never knew what it was
my dad gave me i left home from the
airport one night after i'd been in
london for a week
and i was twitching like [ __ ]
to the point where he started crying in
the car
because he was like this is like a game
i never knew it was threats at this
point he was like this is [ __ ] like
so like he thought i was having like a
seizure next day in the car and i was
mad so like
they were obviously concerned and
they're like why like just stop don't do
this if it's making you feel less [ __ ]
you never had any of this anxiety and
before
this all took off but then again when i
went to therapy i was like
oh i actually did but this kind of just
tipped it over the edge maybe when it
became like panic attacks and stuff like
expect the live thing was really was
really a big thing we went and played um
the grand prix in abu dhabi in december
of last year
um
just like i said and i was really
worried about that and then
we came we went on stage and i never
i've never had any of those issues like
i didn't twitch i didn't have a panic
attack whatever and i came off
and i was in the toilet and i was like i
could have [ __ ] busted the tails
because i was like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] i can
actually do this still and not have be
[ __ ]
twitching and not be [ __ ] terrified
and not all this [ __ ] i mean so um so
that was like a big a big thing but yeah
overlockdown stuff i definitely thought
initially when it happened it was such a
relief because i was like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] i
don't have to go away and do this to her
mm-hmm
and then go and do festivals
because it was like it kind of gives
gave me a moment to kind of address it i
don't know
saying that obviously no
covered dead and
all the stuff that happened and people
lost jobs and all the rest of it
that feels like a like a selfish thing
to say but at the same time it's like
like i don't know how long how much
longer i could have kept up
having a panic attack every single
[ __ ] night on stage and just like
because it was it was like [ __ ] that
was like i i was suffering for sure um
and yeah it just wasn't it wasn't fun
but again it was like i would come off
stage and be absolutely and then i'd be
like oh i'm not i'm not this bad i got
to a point where i was having panic
attacks
because i was anticipating having a
panic attack
you know i mean so when you get into
that cycle i think you're in real
trouble because it's like if you go
looking for something you're gonna
[ __ ] find that i mean you talk about
um how therapy helped that's really
inspiring to hear because a lot of the
time honestly when i sit here with
people who are um in that phase of their
life who have been through that they
didn't seek out help until much much
later in life until you know much much
later after their career yeah um
what val and it's also i have to say
it's so
important and nice to hear your honesty
about that because
i think
we all i think therapy is something that
we should probably all consider if we
have the means to do it because
um it's sometimes not
like whack-a-mole of seeing a symptom
but a preventative measure as well how
was it you can't wait until
things are worse to do something about
it it has to be something that you
continue to [ __ ]
continue to work at like you know what i
mean it's just i think people wait until
it's like
[ __ ] like the worst rock bottom
if you take the steps prior to rock
bottom you might not have to reach that
man how has it helped you and what does
it taught you because you know
i've had a few i've had a few um
i've i've tried a few different
therapists and that's the thing as well
now it's like you kind of go to like
different people when you kind of walk
out i think a lot of people might go to
a therapist and go ah that doesn't work
for me but you have to kind of find the
person yeah exactly exactly so you have
to find the person who's right for you
um and i'm still like i'm still like
i've just started with a new like i'm
still like
trying to find the right person but like
i think um
it's just for me it was all about like
understand that like
the first one i did was like cbt yeah
yeah therapy for my anxiety and i was
like it was just about understanding
what anxiety is and why i'm having these
and
what like looking out for triggers and
things like that it was it was very much
about because at the start when it's not
when you're just having plans actually
like oh what the [ __ ] is going on this
is mental like why am i feeling this and
then every sort of feeling you get when
you have a panic attack spurs it on even
more and it becomes a big [ __ ]
massive thing and i think when i went to
cbt therapy and she was like have you
felt like this if you feel like this you
feel this and i was like oh yeah all
that [ __ ] and she's like oh that's
anxiety and then i remember i used to
this passing out and seizure thing
became a big thing as well when i was
having panic attacks
and she was like right well what happens
if you go if you have a seizure
and i go say
i don't know i've probably got a
hospital and she goes all right so
you're in hospital
was the best place for you to be after
the season she was like i was i'll
probably hospital she was like right
cool so what happens if you pass out i
goes oh i am i'll probably wake up and
and then i don't know i'm probably
hospital he's like it was the best place
we would be so it's like that's like
[ __ ] i just like really talking it
out and then i never knew what
catastrophizing was when it was like
that sort of like snowball effective
yeah yeah this thing happens then this
thing happens so that was a big thing
and yeah so just that
and then the second therapist when it
was the person who mentioned the thing
about
my
my mum's mum and being exposed to like
death that young
and being around death that young and
kind of just
that being a thing with my hypochondria
i don't know the rest of it and then i
just think it's just it's so funny like
when
they make you like
speak out like think like so like me
saying
hussain so what happens if you have a
seizure and i go i go to the hospital
and say well where was the best place
like i mean it's like so simple it's
like so simple but actually from them
making you say it you go oh it makes so
much [ __ ] sense um
and yeah so it's been it's been a big
help for and again it's like not
something that
i feel like
i fee again it's not something i saw
myself doing i've got a therapy on the
rest of it but it definitely [ __ ]
makes me feel great like afterwards you
just feel that [ __ ]
weight has been lifted off your
shoulders and then i definitely i like
to say i would i if you have them used
to do it as something i would
recommend massively i think um
it has helped me like welcome to it
continues to help me it's that thing of
like
so anything it's like you go to the gym
taste it well i don't but you're going
to tell me
to stay fat like for me like going to
therapy is like can i go to the gym to
kind of like help my mind just [ __ ]
exactly yeah work through things
and having the awareness to know that
you're you are living an extraordinarily
unhuman
life
and i say a human because we're not
meant to have feedback at that scale
we're not to go meant to go into arenas
i mean if we're probably from our
hardwire wiring we're probably meant to
be in groups of ten yeah people we know
and love you know small small
communities not going to arenas with
tens of thousands of people absolutely
man absolutely and i think that's the
thing as well as like
understanding
that you this
experience that you've been through as
as
as as if not the world traumatic is a
[ __ ] big one but as it is
it's a massive switch like i was [ __ ]
playing pubs at weekends taking money
and [ __ ] i was at college uh doing
music because and the only reason i did
it was because i was lying on my bed one
day and my dad says what are you doing
after the summer and i goes oh i don't
know yet i was just gonna play gigs and
he was like are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] work at something so i thought
my friend adam and i was like what
course are you doing i'm doing this
music course when done that so i was
just [ __ ] like portering around and
then
this [ __ ] just kicked off what was your
hope for life then if you could if we go
back because we just get past that part
what was your what was you if i had
asked you at 16 years old what you want
to be when you're older what would the
answer have been i've always just wanted
to make enough money doing music so i
didn't have to get a real job but
anything like if i made like
i don't know [ __ ] 500 pound a month i
would have been [ __ ]
buzzing like i would have been so happy
with that but the first time i met my
manager he said to me uh what so what
what would be your [ __ ] like
ideal [ __ ] situation and there was an
artist called lewis watson at the time
who was like playing
who plays like who at the time was
playing like kind of size venues in
glasgow so that's like 350 people and i
was a huge fan of his and i was like oh
well i'd get like lewis watson and be
like my goal like that's like that kind
of
that cat playing king tuts size venues
i've been doing the youtube maps i go my
manager was like i think you could do an
arenas okay this is the first state
first day i met him i think you could be
doing arenas and i was like shut the
[ __ ] up like tong pish
whatever and then [ __ ] cut two three
years later playing arenas it's like
this is madness so it's like
yeah i just wanted to be making enough
money playing music
that it wasn't
that i didn't have to get
for one of the better one real job
because this is like and this is this is
the thing as well with us
we music as well this is a [ __ ] one
of the easiest jobs in the world this is
a really easy job the actual job part of
it
that's the it's the being it's the
famous side of things it's like
that causes the anxiety and stuff that's
your job is a [ __ ] breeze i'm after
one of my friends one of my best pals is
a gravedigger like i mean that's a
[ __ ] hard job this is a piece of piss
like this is great but it's that it's
the kind of
the pressure you put on yourself the
fame and stuff like that's like a and i
[ __ ] hate being on being like oh fame
man it's really tough but because again
it's [ __ ] class and loads of respect
but um
but yeah so i think it's it's
for me it was never i never thought we
would get to this point like i never
even when i got signed
i didn't think it was going to last and
i've always been told like
getting signed means nothing really
because it does kind of i mean it's a
nice little tech but it doesn't mean
anything
more people get dropped than than
[ __ ]
to [ __ ] become success stories
um
so it's always been like stuff that i've
i've always just
been glass half empty and being like
this probably isn't going to work out
but i'm going to [ __ ] try
and really give it a go but it probably
won't work out so don't get i don't like
to get too [ __ ]
aspirational
and i wouldn't say i'm necessarily an
ambitious person
i do think there's people around me who
are ambitious
and who we have the same
like lofty dreams and they maybe see
something in me that again this is
something that i
cannot be more thankful for for like
labels and agents and prs and my manager
and my family and friends stuff they've
obviously saw something and thought
for some reason that we could get to a
point but personally i just feel like
like i'm just happy to play music and
specifically play live so if this just
can continue to that i can do that i
kind of like big crowds now so it'd be
nice to take a step back for at least
two years or whatever but
if i can play live music yeah [ __ ]
i'll show up and play someone you loved
it any old shape for the next 20 years
do i mean i don't give a [ __ ]
i'll i'll do that man because it's a
buzz but um
but yeah i don't know i just think i've
always been that
oh that's probably what this is probably
the end of the road here this is
probably as big as it's going to get and
it's just like when i even when
we started doing well in terms of like
selling tickets for gigs and stuff i
always thought i never ever saw myself
as someone who's going to have a top 40
single
so this is after selling out tools and i
just thought
oh we could maybe squeeze our top 10
album that was like my big my big thing
i was having a thousand album i'll be
[ __ ] happy and then
it just [ __ ] took on a life of its
own one of the things that i was um
really inspired by and which we kind of
skipped over again is this
how many years of like practice and
repetition you put in before
you got discovered like playing in pubs
at like 11 years old and sneaking in and
hiding in the toilets
how important in hindsight was that
practiced like invaluable yeah so
[ __ ] like
like i wouldn't be doing this if i
hadn't been for that but that's the
thing it's like the love of doing it it
wasn't like it didn't feel like to me
like a chore like a [ __ ] and because
i wasn't aiming for anything it felt
like oh this is the buzz this is the
this is the goal
like we've heard yeah well we've done it
me when i got on stage when i was 11
hiding toilets
when i got on stage i was like [ __ ] i
made it this is good like i mean the
fact that i didn't kicked out the bulb
again didn't get kicked out of the pub
that time that was [ __ ] ground that
was always after um
but i saw i i to me that was that was
[ __ ] that was the goal just play gags
that's class most of my memories are
like going out and getting hammered and
underage drinking which obviously
shouldn't do whatever but it's like um
as that are all related we put gigs on
and we we fight our friends at these
gigs and like we went we went and hired
problems that we knew served people who
were like 16 and like we did that was
so my life has been so ingrained in like
doing like music but it never ever felt
like
even now it doesn't feel like i'm
working hard
nothing feels like i'm working hard like
without
getting to like
the number one record at the time didn't
feel like i was doing much
i just felt like i was because i [ __ ]
loved doing it i didn't feel like i was
working
really really hard again i think it
might be something to the fact that my
brothers are like electricians and my
dad's a fishmonger mums and i said i
know what i can see like a property
craft
compared to
finding
but like i just never saw it as like
[ __ ] oh i'm
really in the pits here and i'm [ __ ]
like
i just didn't feel like i was working
hard and that goes back to like being in
those pubs and being in those like
shake bars when knew i was listening to
you or playing in a restaurant even when
i was thinking [ __ ] if i was eating my
dinner i wouldn't want to hear me
[ __ ] singing like that [ __ ] was like
that and i think that's a lot to do with
like the the you have to
develop a thick again playing in a pub
because someone will show you a [ __ ]
show
non-stop when you're living well i
remember knowing you're 11. but when i
started puberty and the cute factor went
away it was like things got dicey for a
bit for sure things were actually things
were an issue but um
but yeah i think that that and that's
what that's any time i see i meet people
like young
guys or girls or [ __ ] whoever that
wants to
be a musician and it's like what did you
do whatever it's just plague x just
immediately go and play right don't
focus on a lot of people are like oh i'm
going to look this way and i'm going to
[ __ ]
i'm going to [ __ ] this is how we're
going to perform on stage and it's just
like just go do it just go play gigs
don't worry about releasing you don't
have to release music i never released a
song
i never did like an official release
like like any like
[ __ ]
the first song i ever released was
bruises which was on my album that's the
first one i've ever put out like ricotta
went and recorded like a minute and
reconstructed and did some demos before
but that was the first song i have a
popular god dude because i've been
writing songs for [ __ ]
at that point i would have i would have
been 20 when that came out so
10 years i've been writing songs for
with 12 because i started running
sometimes nine so 12 years i've been
writing songs for
i got to a point where i was just like
but it was never in my head about
releasing music because i was like oh i
just want to play live like it was just
this this
thing that i just kept doing in tandem
with playing live so for me it's just
like that's what i say people just go do
it and just go [ __ ] get the
experience i remember going to college
when we were 18
and
my
like all these people who were really
talented musicians and singers and
[ __ ] like
they had never but they'd never played
their live kick and i was so surprised
by it because they were [ __ ] much
much more like technically gifted than
all the rest of it and better singers
and all that [ __ ] than me but the
fact that we were we had played live so
much me and my uh friend adam who was a
topic and
paige who was my girlfriend
ex-girlfriend who
love island one of 2020 but
she
she but she she was the same she'd done
loads of gigs adam had done loads of
things
like we all drove to thinking together
um
and it was like
with that sort of experience and gigging
that we all had became like
it was just so that it was so apparently
that sort of like
kind of disparity and not again these
people were much better musicians and
like singers and everything than i was
but like when you got on stage it was
like
there was a marked difference i think
just because it was like you had that
comfortability of being up there and
doing it and
like i think my voice is that i sound
the way i sound because they're playing
in pubs like that sort of like loud
[ __ ]
because you had to [ __ ]
sing above the noise of people talking
push and like drinking all the rest and
like
i think yeah it says
if i hadn't done that looking back now
i'm like oh that's that was the [ __ ]
that was the the kind of game changer
like this is not an easy question for
someone that's self-deprecating but when
you look back in hindsight as you said
there and you go do you know because we
all do it we go what what was the reason
why i was because you've been wildly
wildly [ __ ] successful i mean i
probably don't have the right words to
describe
just how big
your your records got and i'm a huge fan
of yours you have a music chat and i
really am i like you know um
in the same way i'm a big fan of adele
i'm a big fan of ed sheeran you are your
record your records reached that level
thanks in hindsight so you say okay i'm
doing those pub gigs and the repetitions
there but what else
i think um
no self-defecation
because i'm a [ __ ] although i do
think that was a big thing
for sure um i think
i i remember when i first started using
like social media to do
the for
music it was the 1975 what kind of the
main band and everyone's like you have
to be mysterious and you have to be sort
of like you know they were doing like
the gaps between the letters and all the
rest and it was very like black and
white really cool
remember if you look but i mean it's all
probably archived now but if you look
way back at the start of things i'm like
trying to do that and then after that
kind of faded out
but that was everybody everyone was
going any
cool meetings and i was like oh you had
to be like kind of mysterious cool like
black and white like
whatever
and then
[ __ ] we then went on to just i was
just kind of using it to be like oh i'm
doing this today because i had actually
stopped using all social media when i
was 16. i didn't have instagram i didn't
have facebook i didn't have any [ __ ]
because i was just like
i thought i was being cool and edgy by
being off credits or whatever but i was
actually just a kind but um
yeah i just started using it like oh
playing [ __ ]
dr doc festival in bristol today or
whatever
and then it wasn't until like
i think i thought that we had reached
our peak in terms of like
music and all the rest of it like the
first episodes did really well
and then
they kind of the releases in between
there was a song called rush but these
are songs i still love song called rush
and song called tough
tough we thought was like this angle we
thought this is the one that's gonna
[ __ ] if anyone was going to like blow
up
that's that one
it did [ __ ] all right um
absolutely [ __ ] off
and i think at that point we were like
okay this is kind of racist peak we
haven't reached the heights of bruce's
because bruce's kind of blew up online
um him reese wright hates the bruises
and that's going to be a song and
whatever blah blah so then i just like
didn't give a [ __ ] on instagram and i
was just like
just doing stuff that i thought me like
me and my pals would laugh at and
[ __ ] just talk absolutely [ __ ] shy
and just genuinely like being myself
or instagram
really which was taking the pacific
things and taking the pacific being
famous i remember that the first one
that i remember
was coming back from an american tour
we had played like places in the kind of
nice shows in america and it was this
big spread in the um
and like the sun or some other newspaper
well i don't know but like some other
newspaper
um so this big spread that i said like
lewis capaldi no hiding place now
and when i had been in that and on the
american tour this girl in philadelphia
had given me these stupid [ __ ]
glasses like these stupid [ __ ] daft
cat eye glasses
and i had the moment and i was like
i don't know if it was jet lag i'd just
be an exhausted thing but i started
filming myself and being like yeah i'm
[ __ ] so famous now by the way it's
unbelievable that's me no hiding place
now please [ __ ] stop just talking
partial
put the glasses on i was like this is
again just a name shy not thinking about
it like taking the piss and then people
just really reacted to it
again it wasn't something that i was
then like
and no one was like oh we have to this
is a thing though we just kind of left
it and just kept
the more and more i just got comfortable
just talking to your [ __ ] phone and
taking the piss and realizing you know
what social media is actually a mistake
like just don't use everything serious
just have a laugh and
i think that was like the the the the
big thing on that when it was like okay
i found my feet and i found my voice
and i just started to capacity of things
and and just realizing oh you can
actually just
you can philly just put a picture of you
where towel wraps around your head and
these stupid glasses on me on top of you
can put that on a big massive poster on
the chip that's great
yeah like all that [ __ ] yeah yeah it's
like why not do that like like you don't
have to look good or kill on it or
whatever you need to do a [ __ ] stupid
thing we did that whole christmas thingy
where it was just
close-up picture in my face less and it
just says merry christmas for musicality
there was no way we weren't promoting
anything anything like i just that was
it was all in the tube
no label would ever tell you that is the
strategy to become successful and yet
for many people that will actually be
well for some people that'll be how they
discovered you i remember that video of
you
you found out your net worth oh yeah
no one would ever tell you to do that
never marketing strategy well that but
this is a thing that now that someone
was like we started to see other
mostly male artists
doing it
and like
doing like very close things to you and
not to be like oh you [ __ ] called me
because it's like whatever it's people
taking a person trying to do your thing
try whatever you can i get how hard it
is [ __ ] let's do it i remember seeing
a tweet somebody saying a few years ago
labels were telling people to be like
the 1975 and now you're going to
meetings people telling people we'll be
able to capable i can't remember who did
it but i could probably find it but like
i remember reading that and being like
is it like because obviously i'm just
doing whatever and i'm like is that a
thing and then like i just started
seeing it for more and more people and
then i was oh this is [ __ ] great like
cool we're all just being ourselves this
is great but you see some people doing
it and that's not their personality and
you can kind of see it yeah they can't
fake it either exactly and i think
that's the thing and i don't know
i know i'm not really sure what it would
be but then like someone like
like that you look at it now and it's
like people who are themselves like
dojika and lizzo are two people who just
are themselves and people love them
for it there's a name i'm forgetting um
young uh young blood no an an artist in
america who did that
song about
riding a
horse oh hello nurse
and exactly that's our thing and now
obviously he's doing so much for the
lgbt plus um
representation especially in like hip
hop and all the rest of it it's [ __ ]
it's amazing and i think yeah people who
are that's the thing now you're seeing
people who are themselves it's less
about being like a polished [ __ ]
pop star whatever people people because
i think people now
see through that [ __ ] like people see
like
well you're way more relatable than
some
perfect
beautiful like some like one like a
david beckham model with like six-pack
habs who is faultless yeah and just is
pr trained oh yeah i can't relate to
that yeah of course but then
what's funny then is it becomes
such a part like it becomes a point
where that tons of people start going
oh well that's just i remember being a
story and like this i think one of those
people got in touch saying oh there's a
story that um
lewis has a comedy writer is that true i
took college lessons and i'm like if i
take comments i think i'll be coming
with a better [ __ ] than [ __ ] i'm fat and
i'm and i'm like falling in that joke i
mean i think i'd be able to [ __ ] yeah
i'd have better [ __ ] material i mean
but um
get me something on the phone james he
cast it on the phone but like um
no it was like so then that becomes like
that then turns and it's like people are
like oh he's [ __ ] he's trying too
hard now and you're like i'm just doing
the [ __ ] same thing i was last like
do i mean for the last 10 years but um
but i think that that yeah people people
do
like when you again when you can see
someone's not being themselves like when
we were doing that and there was other
people doing the same [ __ ] as it was
like
that's not i can see that that's not you
and that but that was like nothing
that's probably a label that's been like
this is working for that current yeah do
this like i mean there's a juxtaposition
with you though because because of the
music you make i'll be honest so i heard
your music first loved your music all
that stuff then i'm on twitter one day
and i see this guy talking about his
network and sitting in his like mum's
bedroom being like where the [ __ ] is
this money don't tell the tax man and
i'm thinking that's the guy out here
because this guy is a comedian and he's
he's not serious at all
and then this guy in the music is deep
profound and serious and emotional yeah
it felt like two different people so
that's actually what make for me made it
even more
like shocking but cool yeah surprising
100 and i think i think a lot of people
had that i never
noticed that as like a thing like i
never um
i never like saw that as a thing until
people started pointing out it's like
you know you're not like your songs talk
torn
because i never really thought about it
i mean like i'd always just [ __ ]
made tunes and then was who i was i mean
but it's easier to write a bit sad
things i guess like it's hard to write
about like has it always been easy to
write about something i remember reading
about this moment when someone turned to
you and said how's your life going when
you were like 18 19 and yeah yeah that
changed everything for you yeah so up
until then i probably i was writing
songs and i'd learned how to like craft
a song but i wasn't like writing
anything with any like
[ __ ] like meaning or like yeah like i
was all kind of
making up stories or whatever just like
they weren't really about anything
um
and then you got me you come out and you
go into like co-writing sessions in
london i think i was i might have been
17 on my first one um and you go in
and someone goes
oh this is it's actually with a guy
called green who i still see now and
then honestly he's a great writer great
producer
any ego like so what's going on in your
life man how you doing like what do i
write about and i'm like what the [ __ ]
are you talking like who are you like
i've just met you and you're asking me
like how i'm doing and what's going on
my life like it was almost like
like aggressive the way i was saying i
was like stand over i was like [ __ ]
you like
i just remember thinking that and then
over time that becomes you realize
that's like the people want
like talk about that and it's like
that's what makes great songs is like if
you have these
um
yeah if you have these
real stories behind them and these real
emotions behind them um
and that's not to say you can't write a
great song and it's just god was a good
like [ __ ] i remember years and years
ago that but um remember that robbie
williams song hey oh here she goes you
really do that great chin right but i
mean i haven't i don't know if you've
been like oh it doesn't mean anything
it's just like it's just all like
cool and thing and it's a great song i
[ __ ] love that song but like
it was like
when it came to writing my songs i found
that that was like oh this is the
[ __ ]
this is the thing i've kind of been
missing is like
it's weird that it took writing with
someone else to bring out
more of myself in the tunes are you in
touch with your emotions
i think so i think like i i think it's
really important to feel how you're
feeling
so meaning like if i feel wake up the
one thing i feel sad i think it's
important like there's a reason i'm sad
and i should
sit with it and feel it
rather than like
ah put it off for like not kind of
explore i think it is
quite important to like
try your best to [ __ ]
just just like
not
trying to put off being [ __ ] sad just
leads to like for me a big [ __ ]
hole where you're going to like really
really
you're going to just go off a cliff at
one point and you can't keep putting off
or like putting it in boozing instead of
[ __ ] dealing with stuff for whatever
i see me being happy if you're happy
[ __ ]
great feel it
i always [ __ ] like getting like
really melancholic after especially like
so i just did like my first show and
years
with my band over the weekend they're in
denmark and then coming back home sunday
kind of saturday afternoon sunday and i
was just in my empty flat and i was like
[ __ ] i feel like i feel like [ __ ] i feel
really sad now because i've just had
this amazing [ __ ] like i like to come
down high and let the calm down was just
like thank you but i thought it's
important to like
sit with that and then enjoy it and kind
of like not dissect it as such but just
like
kind of let it sort of
take you obviously don't let it run away
but just kind of like
deal with it don't deny it yeah exactly
don't be like nah i'm grounded i'm gonna
take see now if i'm anxious i'll feel
anxious and be like okay i'm feeling
anxious
that's fine i don't know why i'm feeling
this could be this given this could be
this i know a lot of people who journal
and write down like i'm feeling access
because of this what can i control what
can i not all the rest it um
and i think yeah i try and
i try and sit with things i do think
since i've been famous of stuff that i'm
like less and
maybe in touch with like i've been like
like i've really like relationships i
feel like i've become quite a closed off
person not unlike with my parents or
anything else but like if i'm starting a
new relationship or trying to start a
relationship i can be quite a romantic
relationship yeah yeah i can be quite
like
i don't know shut off like a shield is
that yeah yeah for sure and i guess
that's just a response to
you know
everything that's happened but it's
definitely like
so you mean like when if you meet
someone new so if it's romantic partner
or if it's new people you can kind of
keep a wall up because yeah
yeah and i feel like i can like i can be
i can have
it's kind of like i feel like i can give
this maybe more friendship but i can
give people the impression that i'm like
giving them everything
but really i know like i'm [ __ ]
defending certain things
like what
i don't know just like my own sort of
like
maybe like insecurities about things my
own worries about things because you
think if you share that then
it's just quite a vulnerable position to
be in and then it's like you don't
really know you don't want to give that
straight away yeah yeah taught it
because it might you don't have to react
to it totally hard understand and it's
like you don't really want any
i don't know you just you're kind of
careful about who you
share that with and who's how you spend
your time with in general but like it's
easier sometimes you just not
give that away the end to give them the
like the public image first yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
because that's the thing there's where
everyone has a perception of who you are
and like even if i'm on dating apps or
whatever
it's kind of weirdly one-sided but i'm
asking them a bunch of [ __ ] because it's
like
they can google yeah they know loads of
things and they've either seen an
interview or [ __ ] head on the radio
or
and it's like this is one of the things
i think i'm quite
open and
um interviews and stuff like that but i
do think there's still a lot of things
people don't
know about me like the certain questions
i won't get asked because
of like i've always wanted to ask
someone this question i'm not sure i've
ever asked it but um it's i sat one day
with myself and i thought what's the
question as someone that's always doing
interviews always talking what's the
question someone should ask me what's
the best question they should probably
should ask me because i'd love to ask
that question to someone else one day
and the best question i could come up
with is steve if i was committed to
myself steve
what is the question that no one asks
you
that they should be asking you that
would reveal the most interesting
untapped answer
now
i'm gonna ask you that question and then
i'll answer it myself as well which i've
never done before okay um [ __ ]
i don't know like what's the question
that you think you know if you'd asked
me that if i would have found out
something that oh i don't know
um
maybe like things like what makes you
happy
like genuinely what makes you happy
because i can think about loads of
things i might be sad but i'm quite hard
to like
music became a like a hobby that became
a job
and now i like find in my life there's a
lot of gaps in terms of like what i i
can do to like
make myself like like other than [ __ ]
i'm sorry i'm abstaining from alcohol in
a minute i'm not like [ __ ] thinking
but like i've been off it for like three
four weeks or whatever
just because we're doing we're busy
doing all this [ __ ] so i want to be okay
and it's like other than like and again
this is part of where i grew up other
than like going out at the beginning and
pissed it's like what do you do or like
are like playing shows what do you do
that actually makes you
happy and i think a lot i i kind of
don't know
do you know what i mean other than like
my music and back to me
yeah that's a very
strange position to be in and it's like
i don't know where i would start to like
to try and find something like that you
know what i mean is that in part because
your success took your
your whole passion yeah yeah exactly
yeah exactly it takes your passion to me
because it kind of turns it into it's
monetization
yeah yeah it's responsibility it's
[ __ ] pressure it's your abandoned
crew who've got kids and stuff like that
that you feel kind of responsible for in
a way and then it's like
the pressures of [ __ ]
trying not to say the wrong thing
especially in [ __ ]
these times when trying not to say the
wrong thing all the time [ __ ]
um
like trying not to like
you don't you don't want to upset
anybody so try not to upset anybody and
also the pressure of [ __ ] that first
album did well what says next i'm going
to do like this sort of
uncertainty i think a lot of people as
well think just because the first album
started well the second dance to go into
great and it's just not this is not the
case you're only as good as your next
song i think i wanna one of the things
that i think is important for you to
know is that is not a lewis capaldi
thing that is a human thing i remember
reading one day about a study which i
actually wrote about my book where they
got people to do a task right a game
that they enjoyed doing sure and they
measured their success performance and
all those kind of things happiness and
then they got them to do the exact same
task
but they paid them to do it exactly
and their motivation and happiness
dropped and it's and it's so paradoxical
you don't think well if you pay me to do
something that i love
my joy of doing it will drop that makes
absolutely no sense but you're right it
shifts from being passion as the key
incentive and motivator
to money or
responsibility yeah um and it's even
something i think about with this
podcast because i started it because i
love it i love having these
conversations and no one's [ __ ]
listening yeah yeah totally knowing all
of this and about how motivation money i
just want to keep fighting for the bit
that i love and doing it my way and not
allowing
you're good at this because i know you
cancelled some shows when you just
needed some time it's just taking some
[ __ ] time when i need it and saying
no totally and i think that's the thing
that's like that we're like we're saying
about
stopping before
you are stopped you get drink you know
what i mean it's like stopping when you
have the it's you who's made it rather
than oh you physically can't do this
just now because you're in such a bad
way but what was that what was the
question that you'd probably have to
learn
you remembered yeah come on um
i don't think
people ask me so it would be around how
i've dealt with
the
shift in my life from going from being
like someone that no the newspapers
didn't write about to being
getting emails from the big newspaper
saying is this story true about your
past or your life and like in those
moments
it's really [ __ ] me like it's like so
i've had just this like now the media
seem to care about my life
and
sometimes they say things which aren't
true and i had thousands of employees so
they went back through all of my
employees and remember this one article
where they like found like three of them
which was like 0.01 percent of my
improvements and i'd never met these
three people and they and those three
people had a bad experience they wrote a
story about it um
not bad experience with me but a bad
experience with someone in my business
and that like crippled me for like many
days i was i couldn't think about
anything else i was in like and that is
probably my actually probably my first
experience with something that i would
call anxiety just like feeling like
nervous for like days on end yeah
totally and it's over control as well
i even even with all my experience doing
this podcast and speaking to hundreds
and thousands hundreds of successful
people about anxiety and all those
things and how you deal with it you
would think i would be an expert yeah
totally no [ __ ] yeah
yeah no i'm not and i still don't know i
still don't know how to if i get into
one of those moments
i never got into it before
it was only public attention that did it
to me yeah i mean business pressure
never there's public attention in like i
don't even say i'm famous but quote
unquote like
being in the public spotlight i mean we
go this is a new feeling yeah because
you can't you can't control
other people's perception of you you
can't control
how
how you are perceived by the way the
public people will make like there is
i remember how did the brit awards
to just announce an award they'll be
there like last year or something i
wasn't there performing that i went and
i was like oh [ __ ]
um i can't remember i said i think i
went the crowd was like cheering all
that and i went shut up shut up shut up
very like jovial no one was offended you
go online and there's like comments like
he's so disrespectful because it was nhs
workers in the [ __ ]
he's so unlike that's so disrespectful
my mom works for the nhs by the way
right i've said much more on the shop
but
but yeah it's that thing it's that that
i totally can empathize with that
situation because it's just [ __ ] like
you you've gotten to do this you're only
doing this because you love doing this
and then in your business because you've
lived in your business and that's that
you're not trained and no one's trained
humans aren't meant to have [ __ ]
millions of people i'm going to come
back to something you said earlier
because we glazed past that and my brain
has just gone go back to that sure
you're you're on tinder oh yeah yeah
yeah
i'm dating i've just been kicked off
with tender right because i think people
think i'm a bit important fake yeah so
i've been kicked off with bumble tinder
hinge and hinges the one i really like i
love tinder right turner's great but i
just want to really like again because i
feel like that's no like mid 20s like
that's what people are on um i'm on i'm
on oh yeah i'm on a bunch of them don't
worry about that but then and then i'll
go oh god this i got on this one someone
else they told me again this thing
called field and i was like okay there's
another [ __ ] dating app whatever and
i go on it and it's like
so sexual it's unbelie like it's all
about like
like kinks and [ __ ] bdsm and i'm like
this is way beyond like anything i'm
like
tuned in for but like yeah but kicked
off hinge bumble tenderized because i'm
thinking i'm still [ __ ] 25. but i
think as well i always struggle with
like i don't want to like
there's always like people who talk
about things like with a power imbalance
of like
someone being famous or whatever not but
i'm trying to like work that out as well
that's like a new thing of like i don't
want to like use my fame or i don't i
don't want to have any influence over
someone who i'm gonna i'm dating but
then at the same time it's obviously
kind of like and it's unavoidable yeah
and it's like i can't what am i only
supposed to date people who are also
famous like fit that's a really weird
thing so it's that thing of like
yeah as strange that i i don't matter
beyond tender it's a bit weird and
they'll last girl nintendo she's [ __ ]
great so this is brilliant like this is
after i've been famous is there a part
of you that hopes they don't give a [ __ ]
about it and don't know who you are um
no i i think i'm like
because again it's that way of like 20
any girl from like 22 to 25
is probably gonna no again that's like
sounds wanky but just
age range like [ __ ] nowhere to hide
yes you know what i mean exactly yeah
nobody hey i'm [ __ ] famous um
but i think
i cannot i cannot want them to if they
know
there's nothing worse than a girl gone
oh i didn't even like realize like there
is like i hate that when you can like
tell
that someone's talking about sometimes
it's so [ __ ] totally thinking but
sometimes when
people out like i just doesn't know when
people like
i don't know if you've had this
since like that's all blown up but like
i've got girlfriend mate so i don't know
but like when people come up to you
anybody comes up to you and they love to
let you know that they don't give a [ __ ]
who you are
it's like they almost i don't even know
who you are i don't give a [ __ ]
and you're like all right like feels
mutual like what the [ __ ] is this like
you don't have to come up and tell me
that you didn't know that it's [ __ ]
brutal but um so like and sometimes that
happens in dating as well when it's like
yeah i don't even [ __ ] care about
like who you are whatever and it's just
like
okay this is like you don't have to tell
me that like just like we can just have
a conversation with two human beings
whatever but um
yeah i think i would rather if they did
know who i was that i was like oh yeah
like let your music's killer blah blah i
probably wouldn't if someone was like
[ __ ] like if someone was like for
example if i made a girl a gig
no yeah i probably wouldn't maybe back
like ages ago when i was playing small
games but like now it just feels a bit
that feels weird to me yeah that's a
very big
um thing that feels like maybe taking
advantage of your position so i'm
probably gonna do that i wouldn't do
that don't stop
but i think yeah if someone was like
into the music that's great if someone
was like oh that's not really my thing
but cool someone hated it absolutely
fine as well but um i just think i saw
people to be as up front as possible
rather than be like
uh yeah oh are you that oh is that like
your song whatever blah blah blah but
it's like you just want people to be
genuine right yeah exactly exactly
that's yeah because if they're not then
there's trust question marks right i
think of course of course and i think
that that's again maybe a big thing i'd
like the whole
not giving too much of myself away and
all the rest of it like
and putting those walls up
how how is dating in relationships and
all that in your life now because
do you have do you have um
do you have trust issues that people are
going for you for the wrong reasons
that's the question i get asked a lot
it's like how would you should be like
dragon's den and people know you for
like money yeah yeah totally people
think that you're going to attract a
certain type of yes of course of course
i mean yeah totally but this is m
the really good bit and the trip with
steve coogler and rob brydon when he
goes oh well she's only going out are
you famous because you're famous and i
see who goes but i am famous that's like
me saying he's only going out with you
because you're good-looking and young
like yeah
it's that thing i'm like it's such a big
part right now at least right now in my
life of who i am
and that it's hard to get away from i i
i think that's kony
listen more
for some crazy coincidence more girls
are interested in me now
than there were
a couple of years really i don't know
what it is
but it's definitely changed they read
about your net worth yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
but it's not to say like and i don't but
like
it's a like again it's not a thing of
like see people not feel like they know
you and like all the rest of it and
they've seen
your personality and you've maybe made
them laugh or like whatever that can be
attractive thank you and as as well
you maybe have this er people think
you're confident because like or at
least with people within confident
because of how i am on like if i'm on a
talk show or if i'm on
like my instagram people assume that i'm
a lot more kind of confident and i've
had a few beers i'm going to be more
chatty and
i wouldn't
i wouldn't say so not really again it's
that thing of like
feeling really open to like
people like it's like that you're kind
of put on display like i i feel like
i i hate
i don't know i just don't think i'm
yeah no i wouldn't say i'm not as
confident as i was when i was a kid
let's put that away i mean i don't think
anyone else but like i don't some days i
feel really outgoing and i'm like oh i'm
really chatting some days i struggle to
talk to my friends like see sometimes
i'll just be like there'll be a bunch of
us around there will be honest and then
like three of them will leave and it'll
just be me one of one of the pal and in
my head i'm like [ __ ] what do you say to
your friends again like i mean it's that
way where you just stand your head and
you get my head now but like
um i can't think of anything to say you
know what i mean so sometimes that
happens like there's been times where
i've done interviews people
and i've been really chatty and outgoing
because it's like it's a setup thing
they're asking me questions i don't
necessarily esm anything
and it's quite easy to just kind of look
into that rhythm but where it's like
and maybe it's maybe part of doing
interviews because a lot of the the sort
of interactions i have people are very
like one-sided
ask a question i'll answer that ask a
question whereas and now i kind of
sometimes i'm a bit especially in a
romantic setting i'm a bit like [ __ ]
what did i say to us like what did i say
to this person and it's something that
yeah i mean you get better obviously but
um and plus it's an interesting thing as
well because if someone knows what you
do it's quite an it's like a job that
yeah they might so they might still have
any questions and it becomes a bit of a
problem is it can become a bit of a q a
and that's exhausting yeah yeah totally
you want to be doing that on the [ __ ]
weekend no no i totally 100 like people
asking like oh how's
the gigs going or how's like writing new
music going you're like you're going to
give the dude answers which is just yeah
that's good all right
and you know like they don't really care
yeah yeah yeah
isn't that the worst type of question
when you know someone's asking a
question and they don't really care yeah
of course i absolutely just buy small
talk yeah as you can probably tell from
this podcast
yeah i totally agree but then it's very
again how often
in the real world can you start a
conversation with a really deep question
never exactly that's what it's like and
that's the question yeah we got off to
this [ __ ] great start and it's like
like even
even before the podcast and stuff it was
like having each other it was about
[ __ ] proper and deep stuff so i was
like but in real life if you walk up to
sunday and tesco's or whatever and go
like
tell me about key points in your life
it's like then we were like what the
[ __ ]
you stopped by some bread i mean
i think that's
thank you but um but yeah that's what
i'm saying it's like so refreshing to
have these conversations and actually
speak about these things because it's
like
there's just no other situation where
you can actually sit there and talk to
us unless it's like your family or
friends but even then it's like
sometimes when you go to your parents
you know what i have [ __ ]
big teachers just like be with your
parents and enjoy being with your
parents and like just sit and have
dinner and just enjoy either yeah just
be there rather than be like
oh explain your whole life yeah totally
i mean i think
yeah so these these situations that are
very i mean i don't often have we don't
often have conversations just deep in
front of cameras like that's my cameras
but like i think
um yes
it's always refreshing
when you think so you got
you know you now realize that there is
and i hate to i can add more pressure
but you know there's an exp there's the
people are waiting now for this
for new music at some point whenever
it's going to be coming
um
how do you feel how are you feeling
about that how you feeling oh i'm like
changing the [ __ ] myself the point's
making this [ __ ] new music where i
was like i don't actually [ __ ] care
about this am i just going for the
motions and writing this writing these
songs and all this
and then there was be days where i'm
like [ __ ] um the sweat on this so now
the album's done and every single song i
[ __ ] love and i think is a better
album the first one and i really care
about it and i really put a lot
because i write about a lot more stuff
that i would never spoke about in the
first album like pertaining to
my own mental health and like
my own sort of outlook on things
regarding being famous or whatever um
and i think
like that it was kind of like a nice
thing to be scared because i'm like oh
[ __ ] i really really want this to go
well because i really care about this
album and i i realized i'm really keen
about making this music and being able
to put out and having this privileged
position to be able to [ __ ] go and do
that but yeah i'd be lying if i said
that was anything other than absolutely
[ __ ] bricking it it's like it's a
serious eh
and it's like
it's that thing as well like like i said
earlier where people like ah man you can
[ __ ] shout you could fart in the mic
and go [ __ ] top 10 or whatever just
because the last album
did well does not mean that at all it's
like [ __ ] as nonsense like people
want good music everything the music
[ __ ] that it's not
it's not going to fly do that mean but
you've done the bit you can control
yes 100 but is there not now risk of
putting your emotions on the
uncontrollable like there's nothing now
you can do once you've written music and
you've you've done the hard bit there's
nothing more that you can do to control
obviously you can do promo and stuff but
that's not gonna you know that won't
yeah that's not gonna be the thing that
pushes over the edge yeah no totally and
and as that as like the [ __ ] unknown
as [ __ ] that i can't control when it is
up to [ __ ] i don't know a [ __ ]
higher power of faith or whatever i
don't know but like
it's uh
it's still still quite hard it's one of
those things where no amount of therapy
i think is going to help me not focus on
that yeah and it's like i'm quite bad
for like having anticipation anxiety
being like because i'm ready to [ __ ]
go now like i'm ready to go like someone
suggested that we push things back a bit
melody a bit more and i was like i
cannot wait like any longer to put this
music out this is like this has to go
out and as well if you wait too long
it's [ __ ] the album starts to mean
less to you and you kind of like you get
further away from writing those songs
and what they meant to whatever so um
can i ask you a question yes
if it goes
really well
so if it goes bad i kind of can guess
how you probably might feel yeah but if
it goes really well how will you feel i
don't know this is like i'm kind of
worried that if it goes bad i'll be
relieved
because i'll be like
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] that all that pressure's
off you know i mean like some part of me
kind of feels like that and then part of
me feels like oh no if it goes well i'll
be relieved but then sometimes i'm like
oh but if it goes well i'll be like [ __ ]
i've got all this at least like
i mean there's only like
if it goes well
surely that just means more prying eyes
and more
like fame and more like thing which
again is [ __ ] great a lot of the time
but it has its pitfalls and it's like
will that then
feed into the anxiety more or is this my
anxiety now i've learned to deal with it
or will it get worse or will it expand
or will it show itself in different ways
what would you say to a friend if they
were going through thinking all the
things you're thinking what would you
say if you were if i was your best mate
we'd known each other since we were kids
and i was saying all this stuff to you
what would you say to me
i don't know i'd say just like
remember why you got into in the first
place remember doing that don't
don't feel like you're working towards
some end product feel like you're you're
this is the end product you're enjoying
it this is what you're supposed to be
doing you're here
[ __ ] be here don't [ __ ]
you're not there's no [ __ ] it's not a
destiny like this pure like on a [ __ ]
card but like there's no destination
that you're trying to get to but like
just [ __ ] like this is the fun part
like this is this is supposed to be fun
let it be fun do you know what i mean
because i think the only thing that's
stopping being fun is [ __ ]
my mind i mean so
i mean it's easier to say that to people
than decisions yeah it is you're right
but they say they say i've read the
quote i've posted this a few times
myself where you say you know if you
always go through life believing
happiness is somewhere else then it will
never be where you are
it's like deferring the happiness to a
future moment but it's like a mirage you
see it in like when people are in those
like movies in the desert and they see i
know you're like chasing a rainbow it
just keeps moving off further into the
future
and i think that that's the the thing as
well i haven't done all this mad [ __ ]
and then been to like um the grammys
[ __ ] hate the grammys
[ __ ] been to a bunch other world
shows that i didn't really enjoy
the the what i loved the most was the
awards the night that i had won two
awards not because i won the awards but
because it was like the first time i've
ever felt like oh [ __ ] we're celebrating
this my mom and dad were there three of
my best pals for home we're like well
able to come down and do it the people
who'd walked on the record was actually
sitting at the table with me we were
like like label wise and manager-wise
and that we're like that felt like
an amazing moment and then you realize
it's because there was all these people
there it wasn't like because of you yeah
i'm there and i've won something or
whatever it's because you're celebrating
this way like
people that you love and people that you
that have been through it all with you
and
yeah my mom and dad obviously my mum
gave birth to me by the way
yeah yeah like
so like my mum and dad and then my
friends who i've grown up with and then
these people who have put their [ __ ]
blood sweat and tears and making the
record with me and then
like the label and stuff have [ __ ]
worked so hard and promoting it and
getting out there and
i think that's
that was what like what you'd realize is
like i mean again it's like so [ __ ]
like
cliche however but that is like you were
like [ __ ] this is genuinely
why it's fun like because you're getting
to share this moment with all these
other people when
it's not anything to do with like you
say
getting to a point like getting to the
brits and winning a brick was very i was
having a [ __ ] great night that night
regardless you know what i mean like
there was nothing that was going to like
either way yeah i mean if i'd lost i
wouldn't have been like oh [ __ ] i lost
nice room and i'm going home it would
have been like all right kill let's
[ __ ] kick on i just so happened that
i won these two things i had to care
about me for the rest of the night i
mean
[Laughter]
but then like and then going to the
grammys i remember grammys start to
finish had a panic attack the whole time
it was [ __ ] dreadful hated every
moment of it
and when we didn't win i mean feeling
like oh thank god and like i just kind
of like
melted away because it was like fun [ __ ]
i don't need to go and do that [ __ ] i
don't know if it maybe it was like
[ __ ] this is good i don't know if maybe
in my head i'm like oh [ __ ] if we were
to win something like that that's like
more and more eyes on you that maybe you
can't handle at this moment in time i
don't know if it's my body like
telling me something but
i [ __ ] hated the grammys pish
like all these things were like
and at that time it was just me my
manager and like the guys who wrote
something live with like i think
when you can see the people i mean i
love them to bits but and when you can
see like the people you're
like who have kind of made you who you
are as it were
enjoying the things that you're enjoying
and seeing it unfold and stuff i think
that's the
that's the buzz so how do you make sure
how do you take that with you going
forward well hopefully the record does
well enough next time that i can ask for
more tickets to things i mean that's
honestly like but i think that's like
like it's just keeping those people
close and like that's that's another
thing about coverage and going back to
like
i live for my paint i like i didn't have
a platter whatever i lived with my
parents um because i was on twitter all
the time i never knew the house so i
moved out during cover and stuff and
it's like that realizing like
like
no matter what however things go no
matter where you go and about what
happens in your career i [ __ ]
it's like it's always just going to come
back to that and those people and those
and like where your roots are and stuff
i don't think it's
it's it's just for me that's that's
it kind of reaffirms the importance of
all that stuff
covered like being there and being back
and
yeah i think that was for me the
that that covered for me that was kind
of what
i got out of it and i think for me it's
just
then taking that forward and trying
at any time i can't share
moments like that with people even if it
means that i was doing an award to
america flying some people out and doing
it and it's like
[ __ ] it's like not worrying about
like oh [ __ ] it's quite expensive
[ __ ] it fire them up because it's like
it's going to make the moment
it's going to make them yeah it's going
to make it exactly yeah it's going to
make it [ __ ] what it is and it's
going to [ __ ] that's interesting yeah
do you have any goals looking really
into the future do you have any of those
big bucket list style goals where you go
[ __ ] how that would be i'd like to
write a song for a film
okay that's kind of my only
thing or something maybe not i i don't
know if i'm in fact that's the me
i don't know i'm swag enough to have
that sort of like thingy but um i don't
know man let anything anything would be
good but like even if it's like
i don't know something like indie film
whatever it doesn't have to be [ __ ]
just like i quite like the idea of
that's like a new challenge like writing
for i wrote for a game once that was
quite fun i enjoyed that reckon you
could do it for a podcast yeah yeah
[ __ ] sure
i like it like come on battle in the
voice
i know you're not cheap
[Laughter]
but yeah so that for me that's kind of i
don't really have any like in terms of
like in chat positions
again i never really had that first time
around and i think it's only you know
they're going to be disappointed in
situations like that
i think maybe
yeah i don't really know i just can't
again
it's meant to be fun
and i think me putting goals on things
the way my mind works would
kind of strip that of some of the fun of
it you know what i mean so yeah the film
thing would be good
and i hope the people who really really
loved the first album really really love
the second album doesn't have to be more
like
more people but the people who like
really really
carry the album with them and still were
[ __ ] like
like still [ __ ] uh corrected 10 i'm
still [ __ ] playing it over and over
again i hope that they love
the second record and i hope that did
that and their eyes did it justice
because in mind i have what about
personal goals so like when i when i
look at my personal life i go okay
there's a certain balance and structure
to my personal life that i hope to
achieve someday
um
i think i still need to learn
how to say no to things i think i'm i'm
getting i have to cancel yours before
and all the rest of it but i i'm quite
bad at like i [ __ ] if i say no with that
that's an opportunity that just won't
come back or whatever um i need to learn
i'd like to be able to do that
um just for my own sort of personal life
um
i'd like to do some traveling that isn't
relating to work at some point
i guess that's like taking time for
myself i would like
that was kind of the plan over covert
like well what what became covered i was
going to go away and see all these
places and actually just take some time
so i'd like to do that
kids
relationships i don't know i mean a
relationship would obviously be nice not
something i'm seeking
at the moment wearing all these apps and
just for bdsm yeah just for videos just
for my king chat yeah yeah just for my
uh my kinks but uh i don't know i think
it's still nice to have like i like
meeting new people when hanging out with
new people and um
like
uh
shagging that i guess but
but like just i think right now as well
it's a bit unfair for the other person
if i'm [ __ ] crossing their way and
all the rest of they have to be quite
understanding human being um
kids i think that's [ __ ] right now
it's not in my
plans at all yeah but you're so [ __ ]
young yeah exactly like i'm 25 so it's
like
so i see all my friends having some of
my friends i've one pound's got four
kids um might say just me and it's like
africa's maybe i don't know but i don't
know speaking that much anymore it
became a dad and i didn't want anything
to do
that just reminds me of how like i'm
getting older but um
but yeah no like people are not getting
married and having kids on that that's
just like not my
my bag at all and again i don't have
anything wrong with that people like
doing their thing i suspect you'll meet
someone that's what happened with me
where i was very much the type of person
where i was like it's not fair on them
i'm too busy my work comes first blah
blah blah blah and then i met someone
i've seen this a lot with especially
with some musicians that are like rock
stars like proper like you know rock
stars drugs
and they meet someone and they just
slept yeah because a lot of them going
out and doing stuff like is boredom yeah
that is a lot like i don't know i love a
[ __ ] night out a lot of times you're
like you'll be sitting about thursday
night wait wait tuesday [ __ ] night or
something and you've got nothing on
wednesday and you're like
[ __ ] i said should we just go get a few
points and then you end up out and
you're [ __ ] unimaginable so it's like
i i can totally see that like that that
switch so i think nice because you're
being young yeah totally 100
points that's a big thing as well as
like
remembering that i'm in my 20s is a big
thing for me because sometimes i'm a bit
like
[ __ ] let's just get this done and like
don't not giving a [ __ ] like missing
birthdays and [ __ ] weddings and all
this [ __ ] funerals but i think it's
something that's important to remember
my age and like
[ __ ] like like to actually take time for
life rather than
just
slave it but slaving away at work
we we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the previous guest asks a
question to the next guest you might
have seen it before
um the previous guest asked you a
question but i'm actually going to ask
a follow-up question to this as well um
the question they left for you was not
knowing who they left it for was
kind of interesting question that they
left a few but would you rather win the
premier league win an oscar or headline
glastonbury
i mean i think yeah that's great do you
know what actually
did she that i do think there's
something
unreal about like see being out she's
scoring like a great goal like a great
goal should do soccer aid yeah oh [ __ ]
man i'm sure you're football but i'll be
like a manager i'll stand and say later
in class but um
like the sound of it that
i've always thought [ __ ] that'd be the
best feeling ever like and that but i'm
a celtic fan so like old formed i'll be
like
scoring like a [ __ ] the winning goal
90th minute [ __ ] whatever like that
must be unreal but obviously just
because i'm a musician i mean headlining
glastonbury so i'm gonna so i i kind of
that's why i knew it would be a bit of
an easier question for you so i'm gonna
ask a question which we mentioned
earlier on which was uh caused a bit of
eureka moment in your life which is
how are you doing
um
i'm good i think
um um definitely not uh
i think over the last last two or three
weeks
i've really come back to like being
myself i think i was gonna be in a bit
of a
not like a rock like a funny patch
of the few weeks prior i think i was
maybe going out a bit too much
um
kind of feeling a bit dejected because
because we're just like this well as i
was talking about this long run up to
releasing this first single um thing
about dejected about that and stuff and
just overall just anxiety just like
really [ __ ] getting the better of me
um but i think over the last like couple
of weeks of kind of
coming at the other end of it so i feel
pretty good i feel quite optimistic
cautiously optimistic um
but yeah it's still still there exactly
as i always do but i think
yeah i'm i'm very
i'm happy at the minute which is good
it's most i can ask for
operating at 80
it's a [ __ ] class
i can see the caution in the world which
is just
but you know what i i couldn't be more
like i don't sit here and gas people up
or really [ __ ] them because i don't
really have to you can say other things
i genuinely
love your music thank you sure and uh i
and i really really mean that like i
genuinely sincerely mean that i've
watched your acoustic acoustic tracks on
you your covers on youtube of your own
songs yeah i've watched all of it and i
i couldn't be more excited to hear
whatever you do next and i'm not even
even as a fan of yours i'm not even
anticipating it's going to be the same
as last time i'm actually just so
intrigued to hear
another
another lewis uh another when i say
another side just mean more lewis oh
yeah more from you because you know your
album was actually quite
i think because you have so many hits on
hits on there it can feel a little bit
short in hindsight yes you've played
i've played the song so many times so
i'm so excited for that and
um i also want to thank you generally
because it's so refreshing for someone
to be so unbelievably open and honest
with thing with some of the issues you
talk about because you won't
you won't know until you know after this
conversation comes out how many people
you help by doing that
when jack came on and talked about his
health anxiety jack jack said online he
got thousands of messages a day of
people thanking him because there's not
enough people talking about it what's
the incentive to do so
um there's
there is an incentive but it doesn't
appear to be one it seems to be a
greater cost so thank you for that
because we need to have more of those
conversations and it's like
especially about therapy and being a man
and
being open about your feelings and thank
you for doing this it's a huge honor
honestly thank you so much for having us
it's honestly so refreshing to actually
have a [ __ ]
on conversation and have conversations
about stuff because no one has ever
asked me
the questions that you've asked me today
so it's good to actually
talk i feel later great
quick one we have a brand new sponsor on
this podcast which i'm very excited to
tell you about they're a brand called
blue jeans by verizon and they are a
video conferencing and collaboration
tool that has changed the game for our
team so i'm so glad to be working with
them because as you know one of the most
important things for me is when we have
a sponsor it is part of my world it is
part of my life it is part of my
companies as someone who's on calls
pretty much 80 of the day building my
businesses and speaking to my teams all
over the world it's the guaranteed
security that differentiates blue jeans
from all of the other options that are
out there in terms of video conferencing
their enterprise grade security means
you can protect your organization from
malicious attacks and establish real
trust with everyone that joins your
meeting and that is something there are
so many things that make sense and make
blue jeans um a better option than the
sort of competitors out there and i'll
be talking about all of those aspects
those features and the reasons why i use
blue jeans in the coming episodes if you
want to check it out you can head to
www.bluejeans.com
to learn more my girlfriend came
upstairs yesterday when i was having a
shower and she said to me that she tried
the heel protein shake which lives on my
fridge over there and she said it's
amazing low calories you get your 20 odd
grams of protein you get your 26
vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete and
that has
about 100 calories in total while also
giving you your 20 grams of protein
if you haven't tried the cure protein
product do give it a try the salted
caramel one if you put some ice cubes in
it and you put it in a blender and you
try it is as good as pretty much any
milkshake on the market just mixed with
water it's been a game changer for me
because i'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and i'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where heel fits in my life thank you for
making a product that i actually like
the salted caramel is my favorite i've
got the banana one here which is the one
my girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is
the one
[Music]
you